that's the Cambridge family bringing us
all kinds of cuteness thanks to Kate
Middleton photographs Secotan amazing
ability to tell a story
the Royals first popped up in our
Instagram feeds on Saturday when they
shared this sweet snap featuring Prince
William posing on a swing with
six-year-old Prince George five year old
Princess Charlotte and two year old
Prince Louie the photo was taken by Kate
earlier this month
and included the caption quote the Duke
and Duchess of Cambridge are very
pleased to share a new picture of the
Duke with Prince George Princess
Charlotte and Prince Louis ahead of the
Dukes birthday tomorrow
well I'm very much an amateur
photographer I've done learn along the
way the Cambridge's continued the
cuteness on Sunday posting a series of
adorable family pics and thinking
everyone for their kind wishes on the
Dukes 38th birthday here the future king
can be seen rolling in the grass with
his three adorable children all four of
them grinning from ear to ear but wills
birthday wasn't the only thing being
celebrated on Sunday the Duke and
Duchess paid tribute to their respective
dads on what was also Father's Day
here's the photo the couple posted of
William posing with his father Prince
Charles as for the photographer that'd
be Kate meanwhile here she is posing
with her own dad Michael Middleton in a
rare throwback photo you're not checking
your your father my parents and things
like that really loved and keeping in
touch with the children kissing it's
really hard it goes but hey I'm not
gonna lie with the two-year-old for some
reason he sees the red button and always
wants to press the red button not only
have Will and Kate relied on video chat
to keep in touch with their families
throughout the corona virus pandemic
they've also used the same technology to
carry out their royal duties freeing
them working digitally we see William
and Kate engaging with the key workers
staff and the children at a school in
the UK for members of the
family are trying their hardest to
continue their work to continue their
links with their charities and finding
new ways of working earlier this month
the Cambridge's shared a snap of their
two eldest kids volunteering with
William during volunteers week and on
Friday both William and Kate made public
appearances the Duke was presented with
a birthday cake during his visit to a
bakery in Norfolk England are unisys to
me - and here's the Duchess visiting an
independent family-run garden center
also located in Norfolk during what was
her first in-person appearance since the
start of quarantine
[Music]